[Musique]
dans leur prison dorée des géants de se
construisent tant papier des chimères et
des bombes
dire que petit enfant ou révèle tout son
bon
faut croire qu'en grandissant fermont
dedans
qu'est ce que moi je fais dans tout ça
est ce que j'écoute la vois tu parles au
fond de moi
moi je veux tenir devenir devenir
quelqu'un
pouvoir me souvenir souvenir s'il ya la
fin
au mieux je
cherchais mon chemin
pour enfin devenir devenir devenir
quelqu'un
quelqu'un vient pas pas la barbe à papa
tu atteins
pour réussir sa vie briller se faire une
place
ce quel qu'en soit le prix a pas de
règles il
mais quand on réussit quand on perd
notre audace
et course et son petit et dans nos
prisons de glace
qu'est ce que moi je fais dans tout ça
est ce que j'écoute la voix qui parle au
fond de moi moi je veux devenir devenir
devenir quelqu'un
pouvoir me souvenir sur une aire signes
afin
que j'aurai fait mon chemin
aux enfers devenir devenir devenir
quelqu'un
car bien à palau à papa pas là
quelqu'un de bien a pas d'impasse
map à la ah
ah ah ah papa là quelqu'un de bien
papa pas là
je ne peux plus respirer j'ai mon
cerveau qui crève
les écrans de fumée montant ferme et
meyrin
dire que petit enfant va tout s'en vont
faut croire quand on descend fervent
dedans
moi je veux devenir devenir devenir
quelqu'un
pouvoir me souvenir souvenir souvenir à
la fin
[Musique]
comme joris axé mon chemin
pour enfin devenir devenir devenir
quelqu'un
quelqu'un de bien bal à papa papa la
ligue 1 2
bal à papa papa là quelqu'un de bien à
bas la page papapapa la
kafala pas
là
[Musique]